l'obscurité et un froid glacial depuis
les frappes massives qui ont visé il y a
deux jours les infrastructures
énergétiques la moitié des habitants
sont sans chauffage et sans lumière des
coupures d'électricité qui peuvent avoir
de graves conséquences
ici on opère à cœur ouvert à la lumière
d'une torche
voilà dans quelles conditions pratiquent
la chirurgie cardiaque aujourd'hui
regardez ça
ils vont brancher le générateur pour
poursuivre l'opération sans savoir
combien de temps il va tenir
réjouissez-vous les Russes aujourd'hui
nous avons un enfant sur la table
d'opération et plus d'électricité bravo
c'est vraiment très humain
dans ce magasin on a sorti les bougies
mais surtout on garde le moral la
propriétaire a quelques réserves
reste de l'eau on peut s'éclairer tout
va bien mais nous détestons les Russes
et nous allons survivre
pour soulager les habitants les
autorités ont installé de nombreuses
stands comme celles-ci où l'on peut
venir pour recharger son téléphone ou
trouver un peu de chaleur
l'entraide la résilience aussi
toujours très forte chez les Ukrainiens
dans la nuit noire l'Orchestre
philharmonique de Kiev a offert un
concert pour réchauffer les cœurs
[Applaudissements]